you've had such great success but like a
lot of actors early on you needed to get
work yeah and you would go out for
different advertisements does your
commercial take really crazy risks and
my agent called me one day and said have
you ever repelled off a mountain I go oh
yeah oh yeah you're supposed to just say
yeah say yes I'm doing it right now yeah
and so I said well there's a there's a
Mars candy bars where they want the
California lifestyle and you need to
know how to repel off a mountain oh yeah
I've done a thousand times which I've
never even wanted to do it yeah yeah let
alone do it would just it's a perfectly
good mountain why are you leaving it
yeah they said at the call at the call
they said well if we call you back we're
gonna have you rappel off the
three-story building next door how do
you feel about that fine absolutely
great whoops I love it love it
so I had a good feeling about this and I
call this outdoors company called a 16
at the time I don't know if it's still
in business but and I this guy named
Chad Oh answers the phone and I said
Chad yeah yeah and I go any dumb I need
to learn how to rappel off a mountain
I'm your guy no so I commit chad is
gonna show me within 5 hours how to do
this
teach me the jargon that I need to know
and we go out there it was horrific the
first time I went down it I'm hugging
this you're supposed to be perpendicular
yes he's must be off the sea is the map
to the mountain right I was like like
this right
everything kissing it the five hours I
got pendulum being and doing 360s and
actually enjoying myself right and I did
get a call back I went to the call I was
picked third out of five guys the first
two guys get up there and they're being
hooked up by a stunt man up top and they
come down and they're almost practically
walking down I thought that's not gonna
work
yeah so I go up to the producers and
their director nice
you mind if I you know hook myself up to
a single gold line through the carabiner
and they say I said it's kind of like
packing your own chute you know and yeah
sure so I go up there right and I said
single line so with two lines going
through you're gonna have more friction
so one line you have less and and he
hooks me up you sure you want to yeah
yeah yeah and I would look over the edge
down to them below and I go you're ready
good yeah any time you sure yeah good
okay and then I just jumped off did one
bounce in the middle of the building
twirled around came down did the little
you know coming over here and it was
like you can feel the deflation of the
other guy's it was like that was mine
yeah I got the humor nailed it yeah I
nailed it we we happened to shoot at the
Chatsworth rocks where I learned how to
do this and I couldn't help but at the
end of the day I said you know to the
producer in director you're not gonna
believe this but so ironic this location
is where I first learned how to do like
full circle
well circle four hours ago here
you